team Johnson team heart you guys are
here
start your central intelligence training
same training that our two best agents
Bob Stone and Calvin Joyner went there
spoiler alert I'm in the CIA
are you joking with me right now stuff
I'm not gonna lie to you it's gonna be
some of the hardest training you guys
have ever been through based on my
experience as a ninja warrior and an
American Gladiator I'm not too concerned
about this central intelligence training
I think I'm gonna knocked out of the
park I think one of the advantages I
have is that I deal with figure on a
regular basis in the sport that I do so
I think I have a little edge on these
other guys with that I look through the
team across from me and I thought this
big Johnson is gonna take down this
little heart pretty easily we got too
much firepower we're too talented at
this no I'm not nervous I'm pretty
confident gonna win I will carry my team
to victory
I want to get in there and and kind of
get our hands dirty a little on your
face hurry it up down face down Christ
people it is a push-up you did them in
kindergarten these instructors are
really intense because military guys and
they're dealing with a bunch of idiots
to tuck into cameras for a job get your
belly off the ground knees off the
ground your name Weakland is really
showing it felt here I've been pushup
free since 2003 so that was a little
rough down
take my gun jet we may have to kill some
people come on it's like a bite you get
your guns go when I first picked up the
gun I was surprised that it was a little
bit lighter than I thought but it's very
awkward as well one point I will have to
have two guns just saying the human is
very very resilient so you know how we
kill him we shoot him in the face
drop down 1 2 genuinely couldn't believe
that I had fired off my gun those
instructors are intense they're really
hot - I mean it's we really want to aim
for that magic tea box guaranteed
success right the other choice we have
is the upper thoracic region you gotta
aim for the tea zones you gotta aim for
the % thing that's down there and most
importantly you want to not get shot
yourself I don't really care if I hit
anything I just don't want anything to
hit me go nothing huh nope nothing go
none I intentionally did not hit the
target I wanted them to think maybe this
guy sucks at shooting I know what I'm
doing
alright guys we're gonna do room
clearing right now we're gonna to man
room clearing there's a big difference
between what they're gonna have me do
and what I want to do which is basically
just run across that car slide across
and just like shoot everybody I can we
move in
I punch out and I clear my section go
the nice and slow good job
- yeah I'll distract and you open the
door okay fumus role training that we've
done today was so intense I'm tired like
this arm right here it's like it's so
tired I feel super pumped this could be
a chance for team Johnson the show
everyone out there that we can do this
and we have what it takes to win Johnson
the rock you guys are about to be the
rock bottom I thought of that on the way
on the bus over here but waiting all day
to say that to someone team Johnson is
all talk team heart is all action you're
about to get your first taste of the
field it's all fun and games until we're
out there and then it's serious business
you're gonna recover the code and bring
it back to your safe zone I might not
look it but I think I'm pretty fast go
you ready No
sweet let's go no I said no